uh he's the Manhattan district attorney
and he's seems to be reportedly
considering arresting Trump
on What charges in regard to the Stormy
Daniels hush money payment
so how can they prove that that was
actually occurred see that's the whole
thing where it comes down to how do we
know it is true what is real and that's
for everything in this tattoo comes down
to a spiritual reality so her view is
it's impossible to ascertain Truth at
all so all we can do is find a religion
to follow which simply tells us what is
true pretty convenient I have to say if
it works for you I can see why that
would be much more satisfying and
pleasing than understanding the chaos of
the real world the only way you can know
what is true is to believe that there's
absolute truth
ah you know the reason America is having
a problem is because we need to get back
to God